vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture et l'alimentation
monsieur le ministre je vais aborder un
sujet qui aurait été au coeur de
l'actualité si les crises sanitaires
sécuritaires économiques et sociales
n'occupaient pas et à juste titre tous
les esprits avec un budget de 380 7
milliards d'euros sur sept ans la pâte
21 27 et je m'en réjouis le premier
budget européen même s'il est en recul
le 21 octobre matin un accord a été
trouvé après deux ans de négociations
entre les états membres de l'union
européenne
quels en sont les enjeux d'abord l'enjeu
du maintien voire du renforcement d'un
tissu d'agriculteurs mayans notre pays
vivent de leur production assurant le
socle de notre réalité est en fait de
notre pays
ensuite l'enjeu de la souveraineté
alimentaire de la france et d'une
alimentation saine
enfin l'enjeu de notre réponse aux
évolutions climatiques et
environnementales à la préservation du
vivant
l'accompagnement des mutations à opérer
pour s'engager dans une agriculture plus
durable plus raisonnée est essentielle
il ne doit ni pénaliser ceux qui sont
déjà engagés sur ce chemin bien au
contraire
ni ce qu'ils amorcent cette
transformation qu'il faut encourager et
protéger sans jamais oublier bien sûr
l'objectif premier de l'indépendance
alimentaire
je pense en particulier aux zones de
montagne où les efforts déjà accomplis
seront je l'espère reconnu avec cette
nouvelle pac et les 62 milliards d'euros
que la france touchera nous nous
engageons dans un véritable changement
de paradigme avec l'obligation de
pratiques agronomiques exigeantes comme
socle du futur régime dead et l'ajout
déco régimes nationaux pour ceux qui
iront au delà des minima logo légaux
exigible il apparaît donc essentiel de
poursuivre la recherche d'un double
équilibre celui de la cohérence
européenne et celui de la reconnaissance
de la diversité et de la richesse
agricole de la france au titre du psn
monsieur le ministre
quelle garantie avons nous de ne pas
aboutir à 27 politiques agricoles
nationales divergentes mais au contraire
d'aller vers un encours avait une
convergence des normes
cette différenciation territoriales
quel différenciation territoriale
intégrera le futur plan stratégique
national et enfin quid du cofinancement
de l'état
au-delà des aides superficiaires au
titre des politiques régionales
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est obligé de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation et le ministre les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur sautarel
vous évoquez effectivement un sujet ô
combien important pour tous nos
territoires
vous le savez j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer à plusieurs reprises dessus
moi j'ai un et un seul objectif pour
notre agriculture c'est la question de
la souveraineté
nous devons regagner en souveraineté
agroalimentaire dans notre pays
et là où je suis satisfait de l'accord
de la politique agricole commune obtenue
il ya quelques jours c'est que cette
politique elle va nous permettre de
regagner en souveraineté et ça n'était
pas une mince affaire
la première question et vous l'avez
évoqué c'est que contrairement à ce que
certains pourraient imaginer
il n'est pas possible de faire
d'agriculture sans agriculteurs dans le
beau territoire du cantal qui est le
vôtre il n'est pas possible de faire de
l'élevage sans les éleveurs et pour cela
il ya la question du revenu et vous
l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur grâce à
l'implication en particulier du
président de la république
le budget de la politique agricole
commune a été préservé et de combien
nous avons atterri à 386 milliards
d'euros là où la proposition de la
commission initial était de 365
milliards d'euros 20 milliards d'euros
de moins et puis le deuxième défi
monsieur le sénateur vous l'avez aussi
esquissé c'est la question oui il faut
une pac ambitieuse dans les mesures
environnementales
mais cette ambition environnementale
elle n'est possible que si elle est
obligatoire pour tous les états membres
parce qu'on ne peut pas accepter d'avoir
sur nos étals un concombre français est
un con compte d'un autre pays européen
qui ne répondent pas aux mêmes normes
environnementales et pour la première
fois cette politique agricole commune a
permis au titre de ces éco schéma 20 à
30% du paiement direct soit
conditionnelle des mesures
environnementales
mais le soin le soin de manière
obligatoire
tous les états membres et ça nous
l'avons obtenu et ça c'est une très
grande avancée pour nos agriculteurs
enfin je terminerai en posant juste une
question qui quels secteurs d'activité
aujourd'hui dans notre pays en sept ans
verra 20 à 30% de son activité
conditionnelle des mesures
environnementales et bien c'est
l'agriculteur l'agriculture soyons en
fiers dit le disons cela montrons cela
et portant haut les couleurs de cet
agriculteur qui forgent notre territoire
et que vous représentez tous les jours
journée